Oh George any things we need to wrap up
just all the thank you everybody who
gave us five star reviews on iTunes a
lot of those shout out to TJ Benedict
duh and a shout out to splitting up
together from him Sonny Sonny square
gave us the ustedes time I didn't though
as a variation of nosotros papaya but
that's actually like Oh
tamarind not even though oh here's one
you want to read this one here the
bottom one it's a little longer I'm a 37
year old Midwestern single mom oh this
is from less legal una galleta
Cal EMA I'm a 37 year old Midwestern
single mom who had never heard of Bobby
Lee until about a year ago when I
watched love on Netflix as I was
watching splitting up together
oh there you go babe as I was watching
someone complement some of us but as I
was watching splitting up together
I recognized Bobby and also felt his
depiction of his character was endearing
so I googled him I had no idea he was a
comic I watched videos of him with news
anchors and was so impressed with his
energy and sense of humor then I
discovered this podcast and have not
stopped listening in over a week
Wow I work from home and most days feel
a sense of loneliness that I miss in a
typical work environment Bobby kalila
George and Gilbert are my new best
buddies it is refreshing how often taken
open they are with their lives in
Hollywood and a great escape from the
mundane reality of Indiana and the
soccer-mom life Tiger belly watch out I
believe with this new hit TV show see
babe you will see that your audience
grows and a wide variety of women like
me will start following and Bobby if you
read this I was compelled by your first
by your acting first to find out more
about you you don't need to worry about
being good enough you already are and we
are all cheering for you warning don't
listen around your kids that was from
Leslie dilemma Thank You les those nice
as sweetest can't come
mommy thank you you don't need to leave
those long around yeah you know but but
that would we appreciate him or some
other review that's personal I like that
from bonerific George is a modern-day
Bab Bab abui Bobby is an Asian Howard
Stern Gilbert is Fred in Cola Khalifa is
Robin my point is this fantasy is an
illusion keep up the great work I'll
keep listening with my kimchi ice
cocktail can I just point something out
that's really bothering me so you've
handed us this piece of paper with
reviews but you've underlined you've
underlined the sentences where they're
giving you praise hey you know if you
want Fred you're fired
[ __ ] gross and we're not even gonna
read that all right let's go
[Music]